what are your thoughts now with the
hashtag me too and there's this open
discussion and people are speaking up
finally especially women well I just
thank God because I don't think any of
us knew how prevalent this was what was
going on and I'm just so happy that it's
coming to the surface and that women are
now talking about it speaking about it
and men as well and we're having
conversations we're having dialogue and
you know I've had conversations with
friends close friends they know my most
intimate secrets and yet we've never
shared these types of stories just the
other day I was in my driveway my friend
was dropping me off she shared something
with me I shared something with her I've
known her for 40 years so I think this
is happening now all over the globe and
it's it can only be positive ones one of
the most sought-after women in Hollywood
Michelle Pfeiffer is back in 2017 with a
slew of buzz worthy projects after a
four-year hiatus a man was rummaging
around my cabin in the middle of the
night you are silken it wasn't that I
know what it feels like to have my
bedroom in her upcoming film she joined
an all-star cast including Johnny Depp
Penelope Cruz Judi Dench and Daisy
Ridley in the stylish and suspenseful
mystery Murder on the Orient Express
have you ever been mistaken for anybody
yeah I used to get mistaken for ya deny
that one oh uh I used to get mistaken
when I was younger younger as Debbie
Harry oh do people yell a Catwoman to
you yeah they call me sometimes what do
they call me usually they still call me
bat woman based economy anyway you know
so I get the sort of the blondes
of my era you know I'll get Kim Basinger
or I'll get Sharon Stone and I'll get
you know actually I got somebody said
the other take Lindsay Wagner I went
yeah so it's really it runs the gamut
some men have a good look all I have to
do is keep their mouth shut
are you just having the time of your
life right now well yeah I'm having a
wonderful time
you know there are different variations
of highlights of my life and this is a
new chapter for me and you know
empty-nester everybody again about that
so I'm free to for the first time in a
very long time to work guilt-free which
is kind of amazing you know because all
working on is whether you're in this
business or any other kind of business
when you're not with your children
wherever you are even if you're out
having a manicure with your friends if
there's this thing there's this nagging
feeling like I should be home with my
kids and so it's kind of liberating to
now you know this is sort of my time
again yeah